we've got breaking news tsunami alerts
posted for much of the west coast have
just been canceled or downgraded they
were triggered by a 7.9 magnitude
earthquake in the Pacific Ocean that
southeast of Alaska's Kodiak Island the
tsunami warning extended into British
Columbia Canada and a tsunami watch was
issued for Washington State Oregon and
California the alerts have now been
canceled but a small tsunami was
generated near Alaska John Blackstone is
in San Francisco John good morning good
morning well we're now told the tsunami
danger here in San Francisco and along
the west coast has been he's passed the
tsunami warning has been canceled for
the West Coast from British Columbia
through California in Alaska a tsunami
advisory remains in place residents of
Kodiak were awakened with a danger
warning to get to higher ground police
officers in Kodiak Alaska rushed to
evacuate people along the coast sirens
started blaring before 1:30 a.m. local
time
[Music]
[Applause]
and warnings were broadcast on TV
stations in Northern California on
social media Kodiak police urged
residents to get to safety immediately
this is not a drill this is an actual
tsunami warning everybody get at least a
hundred feet above sea level
you have your homes because your family
and be keep me safe Kodiak we woke up to
the house shaking and the pots and pans
rattling in the kitchen Dan Bailey lives
in Anchorage Alaska about 150 miles from
the epicenter of the quake earthquake
happens at midnight or 1:00 in the
morning everybody's you know up
instantly Harbor officials in Kodiak
reported that water was seen receding
from the harbor that was a clear danger
sign of an approaching tsunami but now
it appears a tidal surge of about
perhaps 3 feet is all that's hit Kodiak
so far John John Blackstone thanks